Welcome back everyone this is my new Venom
Let There Be Carnage trailer video.
They dropped a whole bunch of new scenes with
a bunch of Spider-Man Easter eggs carnage
venom even toxin Easter eggs for those you
that want them to do the toxin symbiote.
So we'll break it all down.
And Tom Hardy was also clarifying how they're
working with Marvel on their big Spider-Man
Tom Holland crossover movies too.
If you're new to the channel, be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos I'll be doing full breakdown
post credit scene Easter egg videos for the
movie when it comes out next week.
We also a lot of Spider-Man no way home stuff
that's gonna be happening really soon too
soon with way too long to ask you see these
characters in these universes start slowly
crossing over the also just announced the
gonna be doing a special marvel Disney plus
day and Star Wars Disney plus daily this year
with a bunch of trailer footage.
So I'll talk about that at the end of the
video to rent other so much big stuff coming
up before the end of the year.
It's kind like trailer city.
But the first new scene here is Detective
Patrick Mulligan who is Toxin in the comics,
the offspring of carnage talking to Eddie
Brock trying to get him to go visit Cletus
Kasady in prison hoping that they can get
some more information about all the bodies
that he hid that they never found in his all
just part of Cletus Kasady's obsession with
Eddie Brock just trying to mess with him as
you see there's a lot of tension between Patrick
Mulligan and Eddie Brock.
I think they're just laying the seeds for
potential Toxin arc in the future.
The venom movies.
The way the Tom Hardy explained them planning
that stuff out is that he said they have plans
for another couple of venom sequels.
But they think of those is being separate
from the big Tom Holland's Spider-Man MCU
crossover movies, so for instance, they bury
confirmed that they're crossing him over with
Tom Holland's Spider-Man I posted a clip of
them talking about that in my last big Venom
Let There Be Carnage video when they do that
movie.
It won't be like venom three or Spider-Man
four or anything like that it will just be
like a separate movie off to the side.
They call the side calls because is not quite
a sequel.
But it's kind of a sequel using the map of
the marvel multiverse here from Loki.
This is so useful I'm so glad that they did
this on Loki, because now we can use it to
talk about universes crossing over between
different franchises if the initial giant
line across the bottom of the frame represents
the MCU main timeline one of these giant branches
coming off of it represents the venom movies
in a different universe picture venom three
venom for however many more venom movies.
They do is just continuing along this giant
branch timeline towards the top of the frame
while the MCU timeline just kinda continues
on its own direction, then you have events
like Spider-Man no way home were Dr. strange,
and Spider-Man do everything they can to just
completely mess up the multiverse were events,
because these different universes the different
timelines to sort of overlap briefly and you
can have characters crossing over.
Which is how they're explaining all the Tobey
Maguire Spider-Man characters in the Andrew
Garfield Spider-Man characters winding up
in Spider-Man no way home marvel and Sony
just chose to make that a mainstream main
MCU timeline movie rest the way the Tom Hardy
explained it when they do Spider-Man venom
crossover then be more like a side adventure
it will be like a mainstream Spider-Man movie,
it won't be Spider-Man for Tom Hardy just
explained that that's the way they pitched
when the talking to marvel any to make it
sound like they pitched them ideas all the
time about Spider-Man crossovers like how
about this idea.
Like how about a maximum carnage crossover
and Kevin Feige in Marvel just sort of evaluate
that based on what their own plans are for
the future of Tom Holland inside the other
marvel movies like Avengers five and the other
non-Spider-Man movies that they want to use
them in.
So for instance if venom three winds up being
venom versus Toxin the offspring of the carnage
symbiote they would just continue on with
that storyline in their own universe picking
up where they left off in the events of the
previous venom movie.
But the way the new marvel and Sony sharing
deal works with them, allowing these characters
actually crossover now is that they do allow
the Sony people in the venom movies to reference
Spider-Man things I think you have Spider-Man
Easter eggs.
Like we have J Jonah Jameson and we have the
daily bugle inside Venom Let There Be Carnage.
The only time they get really weird and tricky
with how that works is when you actually have
physical Tom Holland as Spider-Man in a Spider-Man
costume crossing over with venom on screen
any other time.
The Sony people are allowed to reference Spider-Man
related Easter eggs and even more so once
Tom Holland actually crosses over with venom.
The reason why you can see a lot of those
Spider-Man Easter eggs in the first venom
movie is because they were playing it safe
and they made that movie before they signed
the brand-new Spider-Man sharing deal.
But then it is other trailer footage you have
a much longer version of him going to see
Cletus Kasady and Cletus Kasady getting the
carnage symbiote which is they explain here's
a bit of a change from the comic book version
it's still sort of venom's offspring, but
is like the venom symbiote mixing with Cletus
Kasady's blood and the combination of their
DNA just completely changing it into a wholly
different symbiote.
Speaking of which, he also says to Eddie in
the trailer footage.
I would like to introduce you to carnage and
then obviously the carnage symbiote comes
out usually it's the symbiote that wind up
naming themselves.
Like the Klyntar their race.
They have their own names their own identities
solicit misremembering I think they were actually
accurate to that in the first venom movie
where the symbiote was already named venom
and told Eddie that its name was venom.
Like Eddie himself didn't give it the name
venom.
The way they played in this trailer makes
it sound like Cletus Kasady gives his symbiote
the name carnage for the reason why that might
happen is because it's a brand-new symbiote
this just being born when it enters his body
basically is supposed to the other symbiote
from the first venom movie, which were alive
for a long time.
Like matured by themselves and then came to
planet Earth.
Like they already fully developed as symbiote
before they started bonding with people on
earth.
Speaking a maximum carnage in the shriek character.
They also just released a brand-new scene
of shriek inside her cell and Ravencroft Institute
the interesting thing about her character
is that even though she's a Spider-Man character.
Like she debuted in the Spider-Man comics.
She debuted as a mutant in then everybody
just wondering what's going on with really
mainstream mutants in Marvel phase 4.
What about the X-Men characters.
How will they explain her powers in this will
Sony be allowed to use the term mutants in
the venom movies.
The way they explain her backstory in the
Spider-Man comics, is that when she was younger
she was shot in the head and then put into
cloaks special cloak from cloak and dagger
which X is sort of a gateway to the dark dimension
and exposure to the dark dimension energy
awakened her latent mutant abilities and as
you can see from the trailer.
She just has a sonic scream that's basically
her power.
But unless Marvel gave Sony permission to
use the term mutants inside the venom verse
movies, the Spider-Man related movies that
they're doing on their own.
It wouldn't be able to have any the other
characters refer to her as a mutant verbally
during the movie, they have to just call or
something else or be mysterious about a be
very vague about where her powers came from.
It just hope that they also work at a sharing
deal.
Like they did for Spider-Man.
But for mutant in X-Men characters to so that
Sony can start crossing over some of the other
X-Men characters one is relevant for their
films.
Which does seem likely to happen.
Eventually, there's a billion lesser mutant
characters from the X-Men marvel comics that
will probably never see the light of day in
a mainstream MCU movie issues is just the
a list characters like Spider-Man himself
Wolverine the mainstream X-Men characters
the studios are more careful about.
But Marvel is Sony can share a character like
Tom Holland's Spider-Man probably one of the
biggest comic book characters of all time.
Then anything is possible a really good example
of a different type of crossover between Marvel
and Sony Spider-Man movies is doing like a
morbius and blade crossover, which seems like
a pretty easy slamdunk if they wind of doing
morbius equals don't worry, even though it's
been a while since they talked about the morbius
movie their still planning on releasing it
in January the be all kinds of Spider-Man,
Easter eggs during that to just because of
Michael Keaton's vulture character as well
as that giant picture of Spider-Man the Tobey
Maguire Spider-Man costume.
As for all those Disney plus trailers and
special announcements, they just made so Marvel
said November 12 the going to have a special
Disney plus day where they drop a couple trailers
and some footage for upcoming series.
They haven't talked about in a while.
Like maybe a moon knight trailer as she whole
trailer.
Maybe some footage from this marvel and announce
release dates for all that stuff then reveal
more upcoming series that they haven't talked
about previously because they have a billion
different series that are in development then
as part of that Star Wars is also doing the
exact same thing the Star Wars trailers were
probably going to get will be a full Book
of Boba Fett trailer that like mandalorian
season 2.5 we might get the Obi Wan teaser
trailer for the Obi-Wan series, which also
features Hayden Christiansen is Darth Vader
and Anakin Skywalker and then more teaser
announcements about upcoming Star Wars series
like the mandalorian season three, the ahsoka
series.
The Dark Side Acolyte is series and maybe
some other stuff that they're working on that
they haven't announced yet, so don't worry,
I will do videos for all the big stuff that
they release as long as you have alerts enabled
for my channel, you should see all that stuff
when I post it my full marvel what if episode
7 video will post next on Wednesday just like
normal.
It's gonna be the party Thor episode.
Everyone click here for my brand-new eternals
trailer video for kit harington's black knight
character and click here to learn what's going
on with the sinister six inside the Spider-Man
no way home trailer.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see the next video!